hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space 2 okay after a
string of failures that no one's gonna
talk about I'm making my way through a
ship yeah that's what I thought ah
where'd you come from a hole no no I got
you again
I'm gun my gun now take some of Ariel
right up to the far wall with you
ah that was much better Lee handle good
than my previous excursion so I'm
grateful for that power note room yes
please oh this looks bad Ruby give it
give give hey hey hey aah
Isaac aah
five all power to the detonator all
glory to the hypnotoad
okay I'm okay see ya behind me No hello
stances this is where the guy bashed in
his head
I know this place this is holy this is
where the guy was like boom aah broham
see my highlight Brougham for that
amazing occurrence I just now realized
that all this black light is picking up
ah shut up
jab Nicole you never let me talk those
you you you
I don't care Oh
do I look like I care I don't even care
about you anymore I'm all about Ellie
now I've moved on it's about time you
did the same okay thank you store me
another Hey
whatever whatever has been one hell it
was that was only a bronze it looked
purple I guess it was black light but
come on owe me a thousand that wasn't
even worth the power node then if that
was all I got
school me jamming a Christmas
Geyer seeker shells I might just go back
to the seeker rifle not after deal with
his flamethrower honky ah I'm gonna sell
some stuff in my store that I'm never
gonna use like that never gonna use it
probably never gonna do that I've tried
the Ripper before I didn't care for it
javelin gun I may go back to that I'm
not sure yet I don't know what do I need
oh I need to find my inner pro that's
what I need to do reconnect with my
inner awesomeness ah I've lost touch
with my extreme professionalism if
there's one thing that everyone can
agree on on these Let's Plays its
professionalism [ __ ]
okay I'm better I'm gonna be better I
swear
scouts honor gonna be better I was a boy
scout for all like one day back and
forth that even right I'm all damn for
tribute why what happened to the gravit
Ron's as that store offline
oh you finally realized you didn't need
to writing to each other good for you I
don't care I don't wash off line are so
amazing everything's gonna burn that box
is gonna burn
yeah shut up yeah that's right Isaac
shut up lady you're not gonna break me
Isaac said so Isaac is my kind of guy
she's a badass barn you do pit baby come
on oh very good yz-plane million
goody-goody partner that is a power node
right here
Oh got some goodies I don't care if I've
missed but tenbu chilean goodies before
i got that one and that's all that
matter fern boxes oh another baby to
roast oh that's not as bad I'm sorry I
said that that's not it
ah no burn I know Jubilees only evasive
skills nope ah come on burn oh you're
dead one
no damn it I mean I mean torn apart
are these like black ones again not
racist just saying all the wrong things
oh man with a frickin frackin I screw it
screw it I'm getting on land and I'm
taking you down oh my god ah I swear no
no no I've had it up to here with being
with everyone on the internet thinking
I'm bad I'm not I've been playing games
for a long time here in here I'm good ah
I'm gonna call this episode my worst
performance yet oh this is awful
wash 15 feet cleaner oh wow ah ah
another hallucination
Isaac keep it together man you're making
it on your own through a haunted station
I'm pretty up Falls I need more help
kids I'm completely out pretty frack ah
I saw that what the heck is that
looks like a high come on no there you
go ah come on why why you gotta be like
that you just gotta get off it
let me feel secure enough so that you
come out of nowhere at ten million miles
an hour and stab me to no health I swear
ah no no Oh a black one are you guys
nope detonator time suck on it two of
them I don't care I'm finishing this
with D detonator bump Buddha doop bump
sped it up Bob Breuder do I don't care
at all about any of you or anyone around
me what do you luck doc to me hi Brandon
Oh Brandon potentially story line 7 it
is critical that know okay that explains
a lot public it is disturbing that such
record still exists
incident wait how many years after the
incidence access and we'll be replacing
that with ourselves specialist effective
immediately wait how how far into the
future is this he said years I'm
assuming that means you're more
obviously but I mean in video game talk
that's usually three or four ah eat some
detonator you should yeah
oh what's that I saw that just try and
get me nope
home face I will have none of this not
today just come on come on man yeah ah
right in the face
good exactly what I needed ha haunted
lamp he got behind me what I can't I
can't deactivate that one well why not
huh what makes that one so special
oh it wants to die for wants to protect
me that's beautiful
thank you detonator alley-oop
ah fine stock today come at me bro
pwnage poon dogle I think boondoggle is
a different thing but I got you all of
you detonator rules yeah see station
blackout NIDA
I don't need to save I read up on
hardcore and about how you can only have
three saves throughout the game I've
been considering it but if I did it
would be like a livestream event go
until I die
Hey Baby how you doing all right are you
so fun exposed to full power from here
great songs it's works anytime you ready
whole set oh wait few signal uh-huh yeah
everything's gonna go fine I imagine
nothing can go wrong oh this is where I
first saw hammy we're not first song but
first was able to get back in touch with
okay what did that do
a home of Samus I'm an idiot
malfunction Oh No
I doesn't seem good oh they're pulling
the entire station to the ship really
just go I'll usually escape on civility
there
haha
shut up hell yeah time to go
I could totally gods and Clark's voice
actor time to go babysit death ah isn't
that the pod where they had the ah fu
mo segment of your imagination get over
it Isaac you might want to launch after
you close who do I get to pilot yeah
launch
not away I'm away did you make it weak
off the track
we're going in water how hot
oh boy you come on Stross
don't be so pretty my piloting here I
don't think so Oh ah George proximity
alert that's bad
[ __ ]
I like
a character well I mean I can like
shut up I destroyed that
yeah I get it you're blaming us shut up
you maybe die whatever
I guess actually that's actually
interesting really have time to send a
video message right now get off our oh
come on why you gonna oh oh god okay so
Ellie obviously isn't gonna betray me
but Rach I always let the pretty ones
get killed huh Ross went crazy he
murdered his family Oh something the
original betrayal [ __ ] I should have
heeded that warning it's obviously he is
crazy
and he is gonna kill everyone alright
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode thank you guys so much for
watching and for sticking with my
terrible terrible performance throughout
this game anyway thanks again everyone
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part
bye bye